today we are going to visit out Adams
where chef Keith is cooking California
sulfate y8 California Sophie let's find
out
so this is Alta Adams located on West
Adams in Versailles I'm the executive
chef Keith Gorman
thank you for having me today could you
explain what's kind of for the us having
our time is unique in his own way
because we're doing California so what
my passion is why it's sulfate oh yeah
so food for me is full created with love
with the intent to nourish sustain and
feed the soul and have a lunch
your wife packs you and lips it's a
peanut butter and jelly cells but it's
soul food because she got up with the
loving intent to make you a sandwich to
nourish you so oxtail it's this
signature dish like still every
signature dish I started peppery and
then a corona on a flattop for high seal
get it real real hot just to calm Eliza
just a lot get some flavor and give it
another dimension another depth at the
same time preparing the vessel stock
which is kind of carrot slicing onions
celery ginger and garlic put salt over
it let that out bring out that flavor
they're not brown it and I make a
vegetable stock to braise in it which I
add miso is so nice on the fire nice
also which is unfamiliar for traditional
I've stills
do I taste nice honest I know you know
so this also has an umami so it just
gives that oh it's a bechamel yeah it's
very interesting curds and from Japan
and I cannot imagine how it's gonna be
bring it together so I can imagine
California without
Japanese presents their southern
presence that's California the food here
also represents that California soul
food means a lot of different
backgrounds bringing us together
the funny part about it is we didn't
lose the authentic flavor or taste it
still reminds you of eating traditional
southern soul food we just show blaze
our own way to get to that point as far
as I feel I've transferred to a roasting
pan and I take the co dog's tail and I
into that flavored with it and then I
slow cooking at about 250 to 275 over P
about four to five hours and that's just
a nice controlled heat because the
intent is to have the meat tender enough
to be when you touch it it comes right
off the bone but I don't want all the
meat off the bone because when you plate
it
do you want to be able to have a
structured are still so that's why I
cook it nice and slow and even some
pickle Fresno peppers just sprinkle it
over the top so that brings a nice heat
but then all salt and vinegar it just
cuts to the fat I like to cook with salt
and acidity and just bring something to
food let me go it's huge
yeah see so the food is design for
family style so exactly what we're
serving we say it's a vacuum off before
we eat it in Japan okay oh so you say
things well we say grace was the same
thing go ahead and say it I gotta say
just that potentional fort it falls
right off right tasted me so it's like I
don't know right ya know sometimes like
fibrates me it's overpowering but still
kind of taste like a traditional braised
beef probably so you kind of roll it up
it almost look like one big leaf but
traditional beans inside okay so you
have a breached core degree inside and
outside its kind of presentation what do
you want it to make it nice and a gift
oh yeah
so wrap it up like a prison I was
wondering why soul food but I feel like
you uncaught it for me you might have
some that hold on to the fact that so
food is Louisiana
that's what southern soul food came out
of that's why the titles did submarine
so food not so full so food is a
of his own because now we have
California soul food so the last
question what's kind of advice you want
to give to young Chefs or people through
even a difficult situation well for me
the kitchens been my way out the
kitchens been my new beginning it's not
the way but it is a way
anything you do don't be complacent
don't make it a debt in see where you
can go with it and strive to always
continue to go and then when you reach
where you think the max is open another
door for somebody else and I gotta go
back to when you can forgive back to
anything
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]